(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
mark, would you like
to go in with me?
You'd be insane
not to take that.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'll give you more cash.
Did you just jump in
on my geek?
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Mama taught me
how to bake.
This company's gonna be
a lot bigger than $10 million.
(Robert) Wow.
Wow.
It's sink...
you're telling me
you can't
control your own destiny.
Or swim...
this girl served 15 months
in Afghanistan for you.
So...
wow.
While you were making money!
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of QVC,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold
his first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
First into the shark tank
is J. Jones,
an American who believes
he has perfected
a traditional English Treat.
Hi, I'm J. Jones
from Denver, Colorado,
my company is Jones Scones.
And I'm asking for $100,000
for 25% of my company.
Let me tell you
why Jones Scones are awesome--
It's because they're authentic.
They're just like the scones
you would find in England,
and not the cardboard,
icing-covered copies
that you find
in some coffee chains here.
Now I started making scones
for the usual reasons,
and that's pretty much
England and women.
When I lived in England,
I was there for school
and some other adventures.
I fell in love
with my local bakery's scones.
And when I came home
to go to law school in D.C.,
I could not find a scone
that did not taste
like compressed sand.
So mama taught me how to bake.
I made a scone.
And I would make them
for friends,
they helped out
when I was dating.
So I put my law career on hold
and I dove in headfirst.
Had no capital.
I was delivering scones
in my jeep.
So I have some scones
for you to try.
Some blueberry.
Blueberry?
That's blueberry.
Thank you.
How about you, Lori?
What do you want?
All right. I'm a chocolate girl.
Is there a chocolate?
Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
Thank you.
Is that blueberry up there?
It's blueberry.
Hey, save me a blueberry.
You want a blueberry?
Yes, sir.
Mark, you can share
half mine.
That's what's up right there.
(Robert)
J., why is it so dry?
Is that on purpose?
Our scones
tend to be more moist.
If you're experiencing
a dryness,
I find that
to be unusual.
Scones are on
the drier side.
They're not like
a muffin. More like a biscuit.
Are scones typically
a breakfast food?
Yes.
They are.
J., what are you selling
in terms of the scone?
Are the... are the scones
selling cash?
Yes. Uh...
how much?
We are selling right now
$5,000 worth of scones a month.
(Lori) a month.
A month.
Yes.
Why are your scones better
than the other
typical scones?
Well, number one,
that cream style
that we talked about.
Number two,
they're all natural.
So we found a home
in Whole Foods.
You're in Whole Foods?
One store, right?
(laughs) No.
We're in--We're in
six stores now,
uh, in the Denver/
Rocky mountain region,
and in Utah.
Why can't you get
all the stores?
We were. And, uh, might as well
kick into the sales talk.
At one point,
we were selling
$113,000 worth of scones
a month.
We sold
a half-million of these
over the course
of the life of the business.
What happened, J.?
Well, uh... (laughs)
This is why we're here.
This is not good.
Is this a bad story?
No, it's not a bad story,
'cause I'm here.
All right. Tell us.
What we did was,
we expanded.
We went from Denver
out to California,
and we picked
a new manufacturer.
Terrible mistake.
I was not able
to oversee my co-packing
the way I should have.
And when I had to correct
that mistake,
we didn't have
the capital to fix it.
We had to pull back,
so sales came back down
to $75,000 last year--
Or 2 years ago,
and $65,000.
So they didn't manufacture
good product for you,
was that the problem?
They didn't do it right.
You couldn't oversee it,
so you couldn't
come in and test it...
it's not their fault.
It's my fault. I should have
been out there more
to watch the product.
And frankly, I should have
been talking to people like you
before I expanded, because
we would have had the capital
to maintain the ground
that I worked so hard to earn.
Are those same stores now
willing to give you
another chance?
Yes. We know that in Denver,
and we believe so
in California.
How long have you been
in the Denver Whole Foods,
and how many times
have they reordered?
Seven years.
Seven years?
(Robert) seven years?
Yeah.
We went from selling
$37,000 worth of scones
in '07
to selling $60,500
in '08
to selling $113,000
in 2009.
I'm just--I'm not
a big scone guy.
I could tell. (laughs)
Um, but when I
walk into a whole foods today,
do I see
only Jones Scones
or do I see multiple
manufacturers of scones?
People have
done scones locally.
Nobody has gone
into the scones category
and said, "Hi, I'm Jones."
We've got a brand. We've got
someone you can attach it to.
So it's a fragmented market.
You're trying
to become the brand.
Absolutely.
Yeah, but after six,
seven years
of around $60,000,
one year popped to $130,000...
what will $100,000 do that
will be so magical this year?
We are going to
hire food brokers,
which is the way to get
our sales force out there.
The biggest cost that we have
is feeding people the scones.
You know what, man? J.,
you are such a likeable person.
Um, I just don't like it.
Well, let me continue
on--on how...
you don't
have to with me. I like...
I like you, but...
I'm out.
Okay.
We looked at what we can sell
the scones for.
Whole foods, actually,
each store Sells
$368 worth of scones
selling 12 cases a month.
That says we're gonna have
about a quarter of
a million dollars in sales.
Potential. But here's
the reality that I see--
You've been in business
for ten years.
Your sales in the last three
have actually declined.
Lots of potential.
Tell me what you've learned
in the last few years
that when you wake up tomorrow,
it's gonna be a different day
than it was in the past.
Team. That's the next part.
Team.
I've got a guy that can guide me
with what I'm doing.
That's bull crap.
What you're telling me,
without any uncertainty
whatsoever,
is you can't control
your own destiny.
I-I hate to agree with Mark,
but I agree with him 100%.
You're looking for answers
from people outside of yourself.
I hate when people
tell me
the answer to my salvation
is a consultant.
Yeah. No kidding.
No, I'm--I'm not
looking for a consultant, guys.
But you are.
That's what you just said.
Wait, no, he just said
his "Team." His "Team."
But every one of you
has a team.
Every one of you
has somebody that you rely on.
But now you make
the final decisions.
Here's the thing, though--
When I hear you say
that you've been ten years
in the business,
and you're where
you are right now,
needing
to ask us for money,
it tells me
something's wrong.
There's some reason
why this isn't taking off.
I'm not sure what that is.
I thought the scone was fine.
But for me,
I need to love the product
and feel passionate
and want to eat it constantly.
And I'm not at that place.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Sorry to hear that.
What else
can I answer for you?
How can--How can
I bring us closer?
Well, J.,
here's how I see it--
I agree with you.
Nobody wins without a team.
But I don't have time to be
part of that overall team.
I wish you all the best,
'cause you're a very nice guy.
But I'm out.
Mr. Wonderful?
You know, I don't get
emotionally involved.
The scones are good.
I eat scones.
But there's nothing proprietary
about making a scone.
All there is
is executional excellence.
And on that test,
you failed once.
Doesn't mean
you can't recover.
But cutting your sales in half
in a commodity business
like scones is never good.
Look, this is about money.
And I can't make any
from what I see. I'm out.
Well, I have to thank you
for your time.
Good luck.
Cheers.
And I'm out. (chuckles)
Mark never said
he's out?
he was out? (laughs)
I gave him a little quickie.
I gave him
a little quickie.
(laughing) That's a first.
Bye. (laughs)
He gave up.
Something new every day.
Oh, my goodness.
♪♪
Next up is Brian Altomare,
whose business aims
to help people
with their extra baggage.
Hi. My name is Brian Altomare,
and I'm from New York.
My company is Lugless,
and I'm here asking
for $100,000
for 10% equity.
Sharks,
people are tired of paying
ridiculous airline baggage fees,
tired of lost luggage,
and tired of T.S.A.
pilfering through their luggage.
So are we.
That's why we've solved
these problems forever.
Introducing Lugless--
A door-to-door
luggage shipping service
that picks up your luggage
from your home, office, or hotel
and sends it to wherever
you're going ahead of time.
And when your trip is over,
we'll pick your luggage
right back up
and send it on home for you.
We send luggage
to over 200 countries
365 days a year.
We sleep, eat, and breathe
luggage shipping.
Our mission is to be
the voice of reason
in a world gone mad
with baggage fees
and bring back
the joy of traveling
for millions of passengers
who deserve
a better travel experience
with or without
a first-class ticket.
Brian, hasn't this been done?
It's called Fedex.
(Lori) Mm-hmm.
It has.
Fedex does do shipping.
But not like us.
Okay, what's the difference?
The difference is, is that
we have a proprietary system
and we have
service flexibility.
Sorry. Sorry.
Fedex--
Fedex, $40-Billion company,
I believe, last year,
they don't have anything
proprietary or a service--
of course they do. I probably
shouldn't have led with that.
Most importantly
is service flexibility.
Some of the differences--Let's
talk about price real quick--
Is any express or international,
we're 20% to 60% less
than if you went directly
to Fedex.
'cause your bulk buying?
We're bulk buying.
We have deep discounts.
Okay, so walk me through it.
Okay, so let's say, Mark,
you're going to new York...
okay.
For an upcoming Mavericks,
uh, knicks game.
Right.
All right. Um, your private jet
is in the shop,
so you have to fly commercial.
Whoa.
Oh, my--
That's not gonna happen,
so go ahead.
You don't want to lug
your bag
and you want it waiting for you
at your hotel when you arrive.
Perfect.
Right.
So first you go online,
sign up
in less than five minutes.
And then...
you receive a packet
from Lugless at your door.
You open it up...
and you place the reusable
plastic luggage tag
on the handle of the suitcase
that you're sending.
Okay, well, there's--
There's a red flag right there.
How long does it take for me
to get the--the package?
Overnight.
So you can't help me
right now?
Absolutely.
You don't need this packet.
If you don't want it
and you need it out that day,
we have drop-off locations
or we can schedule
a private pickup with, uh,
one of our couriers.
So, you know,
we have a big company,
so we have
our own Fedex account.
Sure.
So you're gearing it
towards individuals.
We are, but we're also
gearing it towards corporations
and companies--
You're saying
you could ship my stuff
cheaper than I could with Fedex.
Uh, I'm gonna say, even though
you have a large company,
we have
very competitive rates.
You have to ship somebody
a package first,
so that's a cost.
Yep.
Sometimes you have to have
a local delivery service
come there,
and then you still have the main
shipping of the luggage.
How do you add
all that in there and it's--
You're still cheaper
than Fedex or U.P.S.?
Well, for those--
Those are add-ons,
and those are
for those customers
that want a little bit more
white-glove service
and they're willing
to spend that.
What did you sell last year?
This year, $215,000 so far,
to date. 10 months.
That's gross or your net?
In revenue.
That's gross.
Net is around $70,000 so far.
Have you tried to partner
with airlines,
saying that
this is more convenient,
and give them a piece
of the action?
Not at this point.
We're trying to partner with
travel-related companies--
Travel agents, hotels--
Well, what's more travel related
than an airline?
Well, they're--
(Lori) Travelocity--
they're collecting $3.4 billion
on baggage fees, so right now--
Yeah, but, you know, they're
aware of what you're doing.
They know what Fedex is doing.
They may consider you
to be an ally
if you gave them
a piece of it.
I-I think it's a great idea.
We just haven't led with that
because we're focused
on hotel chains,
travel agents,
uh, concierge services,
uh, travel portals.
That's really our market.
So am I correct--
You're in
the problem-solving business?
I have my golf clubs.
I call you.
A guy comes,
puts 'em in whatever,
takes care of 'em,
they show up.
I don't have to do anything.
Nothing.
It's all handled.
So it's a--
It's a premium service.
It's not geared towards somebody
who cares about cost.
Am I right?
No, you're wrong. Right now,
with the baggage fees,
second, third, and fourth bags
sometimes is more expensive
than what we charge,
especially for the--
What do you charge for...
sure.
An average-Size suitcase?
Sure. So this--
Like point to them.
This would be carry-on.
That's $39 flat rate,
anywhere in the U.S.
Um, the standard bag,
that's $59.
Uh, this let's say oversized,
that would be $99.
Surf Board's $149.
Uh, and then golf clubs
are $89.
(Mark)
But you're not--You're not
the only luggage shipping
service that's available online.
Absolutely not.
We're the best brand,
and we're definitely
the fastest growing.
(Kevin) The question is,
how do I value this business?
How do I know that...
for $100,000, I shouldn't be
getting 60% of it?
We have a lot of partnerships
that are pending.
I have a letter of interest
from a company called
secure wrap.
And what do they want to do?
They want to put, um,
our Lugless kiosks
that we'll--We'll have
next to them
in, um, in the airports
with them.
So they package your bag,
and they want us to be with them
to fulfill service for them
in their 53 airports.
We'd get business there...
but...
and We'd also--
Why couldn't they just
create an account with Fedex
and do the same thing?
They don't want to get
into the logistics of it.
They don't want
to worry about
if there needs to be
a private courier,
which is one of the levels
of service
that makes us different.
They don't want to do it.
They want it--
so let's say--Let's say
this comes to fruition.
Right? You've gotta
set up a kiosk right there
and hire employees to be there
all the time.
You're gonna have to--to pack
and ship a whole lot of luggage.
We're--We're actually,
I mean, the kiosk idea
is as simple
as just a tablet, uh,
where you can sign up--
but then someone--Then someone's
gotta deal with
getting your courier
or whoever
to take it
to wherever it needs to go.
I-I don't see it
any more than a premium service.
Because it's not gonna be
less money than the airlines.
When you add the local courier,
a guy picking it up,
customer service--
"Hey, Brian, where's my bag?"
it's--right now it is.
It's a premium service
that's going to slowly get
more to the masses
when the baggage fees continue
to remain where they are.
And you're--You're incorrect
by saying We're more expensive.
We're not.
We're cost effective and--
but I don't--
I don't see it.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
The model kinds
of reminds me of what happens
in the cellular telephone
market.
A new brand carrier
like a virgin
sits on top
of the infrastructure
of another company,
and sells
for very thin margins.
You're doing the same thing
on top of Fedex.
I think
what happens over time is,
maybe you scale,
but your margins get crushed.
I think that's the challenge,
because anybody can do this.
And I'm not saying you won't
as you run
for building this brand.
I've never heard of Lugless.
I travel a lot.
I personally, if I owned
a piece of this company,
would push for an airline deal.
I'm out.
(mouths word)
You're asking for $100,000
for 10% of the company.
So you're saying that
the company's worth
a million dollars.
Um, why is that?
I'm asking that for
a couple of different reasons.
Uh, one is the system
that we've created.
If you did what we did on
the open market and created it,
it's about $200,000,
$250,000.
Then we have these partnerships
that we're talking about.
You have that contract already?
No, because we have hotel chains
that we're speaking with,
their looking for
a fully integrated
Lugless operation.
I got it. I-I understand.
Um...
I'm out.
Thank you.
I love
your entrepreneurial spirit.
And I do think
it's a good idea.
But for me,
the problem is,
you're up against too big
a fish right now.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Mark?
You know, I typically like
software plays like this
that are scalable.
Um, but...
you have one huge,
huge problem.
You've got other competitors
that are bigger
and have more
marketing strength than you do.
You're gonna get crushed.
You need an angle
that differentiates you
and just smacks people
in the face--
Quick, easy, cheap, now.
And I don't think you've come
close to doing that,
and you didn't give me
any indication
that you're going to do that,
so I'm out.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
Good luck, Brian.
Thanks.
(exhales)
I don't think they understood
that it's not
just about the price,
it's not just about
the network,
that it's about the industry
and that this is
a growing industry.
♪♪
My name is Robert Gifford,
and I live
in Lynnwood, Washington,
with my wife
and two beautiful daughters.
And my business is called
Geek Chic.
I would describe myself
as a geek.
Any blow to this road
is 7 points of damage.
Ohh.
I'm obsessed with all
the normal geek things.
I have dozens of pocket squares,
80-plus bow ties,
hundreds of hats,
and 30,000 comic books.
Managing that
is kind of the reason
that the business was born.
1-5. Yes!
Please make sure that everything
gets put back where it belongs
and don't leave this
on the table.
(Robert)
My wife tolerates my hobbies.
Like all good invention,
it comes from a wife's ire.
My wife was irritated
by the... (speaks indistinctly)
That was sprinkled
around her home.
I realized I should fix it
if I want to remain married
so I did.
Yeah, we can do all of that
in walnut.
All right.
Talk to you later. Bye.
Since I launched my business,
we've been doing very well.
I need an investment
from the sharks
because I need more capital.
It's the kind of problem that
kills businesses all the time.
And this is too good a business
to not go forward.
To geeks
finally being cool, huh?
(man) Yeah.
♪♪
Hi, my name is Robert Gifford,
and my company is Geek Chic.
I'm here to offer
5% of my company
for $100,000.
So I'm a geek.
But as a geek, I am compelled
to define that nebulous word.
A geek is simply someone
who's obsessively curious
about one or more topics.
Now it's this obsession
that leads us to become
successful scientists,
engineers,
software moguls.
We bring that same obsession
to our hobbies
and entertainment.
Board games, video games,
action figures,
even comic books
are bought mostly by adults.
(sighs deeply)
So...
(laughs)
My wife tolerated my games
on the dining table,
my controllers in baskets
on the coffee table,
and, uh, white cardboard boxes
invading our lives
on comic wednesdays.
But I could see
that it aggravated her,
and in a rare moment
of marital insight...
(bell chimes)
I realized
that she deserved better.
So I started designing
beautiful, geeky furniture
that would be at home
in our home.
But then I had
a more startling revelation--
that we all deserve better.
Well, and that's where
geek chic comes in.
This is a black walnut
3X5 emissary dining table,
but like many good things geek,
it's more than meets the eye.
So if I reach back
down here,
with the push of a button,
I reveal a second surface.
This surface can be used
for card games
or board games
or anything you want to do,
in progress or in storage.
If I pull out of this drawer,
it becomes a desk,
and the desk
is good for laptops
or for running
a role-playing game.
We also have this rail
that we can attach accessories
like bins
and counter holders,
and even wineglass holders.
(snaps)
the configuration
just opens up.
Geeks, by accident or design,
are shaping the world,
and Geek Chic is the brand
that's going to design
and shape it with them.
So, sharks,
and hopefully geeks,
what do you need to know
to become a part of geek chic?
(laughs)
Is this your only product
or do you have more products?
No, no, we have--
This is one of, uh,
19 pieces of furniture
that we currently offer.
(Robert) Can I see it?
(Lori) Yeah, I was gonna say--
So they're all tables
and cabinets at the moment,
or are there also chairs or--
We do chairs as well,
absolutely.
Oh, this is really cool.
And this is the desk?
Yep.
Wow. Very clever.
Do you customize them,
what's inside here?
So it could be a poker table,
it could be a crap table,
it could be...
right.
Whatever you decide to order?
Yeah, absolutely.
That's what--You're seeing
two examples there.
There's a wet-dry-erase surface
that's over,
uh, one of our maps.
(Robert) Oh, look at this.
That thing--
Yeah, that just comes out.
That would be--you could have
that full inset
for playing cards on.
What does this cost?
Uh, about $3,500,
I would say.
Wow, that's reasonable...
Mm-hmm.
For this quality.
How many sales do you have?
We did $2 million
in sales last year.
Wow.
Th--Yes.
Impressive.
What was your profit?
We were negative.
We were in the red by $100,000
on $2 million.
Whoa.
We know what furniture
manufacturers are worth.
5 times free cash.
Sure.
You don't have any free cash.
Why are you worth $2 million?
I'm worth more
than $2 million.
The $2 million is what we did
in revenue last fiscal year.
So what are your projected
cash flows for this year?
Um, I believe that our projected
is about $400,000 or $500,000.
And what are you gonna use
the $100,000 from us for?
Well, I'm gonna use it
to probably buy a truck
to expand
our shipping operations
and probably put on--
Get some more machinery
in the facility
to increase our efficiencies.
What is your average order?
Uh, our average order's about
$4,000, $4,500.
So how much are your margins,
then, on that table?
Uh, about--Well, this is about
$1,800 to make a $3,500 table.
So about 50%?
Yes.
The furniture manufacturing
sector
has been decimated in America.
Yes.
It's all in Asia now.
Why are you staying alive?
Why are you not a dead geek?
Because I am not trying
to compete with China.
China does what they do
very, very well.
But they aren't gonna
be able to make
North American
fully hardwood furniture
in the same kind of way
at a competitive level.
They can't do that.
(Lori)
I-I think you're great.
I love your enthusiasm.
This is a beautiful table,
really beautiful.
I've seen
a lot of tables similar.
I'm just not sure
how you're gonna get
the competitive edge
on top of them
because some of them
are very high-end.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Robert, do you want to sell this
to a lot of people
or do you want to stay
very niche-oriented,
make very high-end stuff,
maybe grow to $10 million,
and just keep it at that?
This company's gonna be
a lot bigger than $10 million.
And we--I want to sell it
to a lot more than--
Than just geeks.
Everyone's looking at this
and going,
"Man, that is nice.
I really do want--I want that.
That's something"--
see, that--That's where
I disconnect, Robert.
I look at that and say,
"That's a table," you know?
I don't--I don't see
anything more there.
Do you see the functionality,
though? Do you see it, Mark?
Do you see that--that--
That's the part--
that part of this is,
is about describing
very specific function
for people?
I mean, I see
what you're trying--Look...
this may not be for you--
for me to get into a business,
I've gotta be relentless
and dive in.
This sounds like you're
trailing down to "No, sir."
Yeah, I'm just telling you...
think about it for a second.
If--if it was Geek Chic
in another direction...
I--this--
but furniture?
I'm--That's just not me.
I--geek furniture is
the beginning
of what we're doing.
It is absolutely the beginning
Well, when you get
to the rest of it...
give you a call?
Give me a call,
but I'm out.
Fair enough. Fair enough.
Robert, let me, uh,
let--Let me tell you where
I differ with your vision...
that you want to be
a big furniture guy.
I don't want to be
I want to be
a big company.
I buy into the design,
but I don't buy into
the furniture company
part of it.
I'm out.
Okay.
I have a story
about biology class...
(laughs)
That may be relevant to this.
okay.
I remember once
counting fruit flies
in a petri dish
with a microscope.
(laughs) I can't
picture that.
And after doing about
a hundred of them
with my little tweezer,
I found one that was not black.
It was white.
It was clear white.
And I held it up
for the teacher and I said,
"What is this doing with
the rest of my fruit flies?"
and he said,
"That's an anomaly."
You're that fruit fly.
You're the anomaly.
You're in
a really crappy business,
who got decimated over
the last 20 years in America.
But if you try and become
a furniture company,
You'll be like
all the other fruit flies--
Dead in the petri dish.
That's what I believe.
I don't think you should
raise any money
or give up any equity.
You should just be
a happy fruit fly.
I'm out.
Okay.
Four sharks are out.
Oh, yes, Daymond.
I just don't know if we're
gonna have the same vision.
If you do this geek angle,
I just don't know
if I can ride with that.
But I real--I'm in love
with the stuff,
and I'm--I'm in love with how
you're running the company.
You asked for $100,000
for 5%?
You're right.
I'm giving you an offer
of $200,000... (exhales)
for 25%.
Now I-I mostly made the offer
at $100,000 for 5%
because I was, you know,
counting the value
that any shark could bring
to my business, for sure.
Uh, how about...
uh, $500,000 for 15%?
(Robert) So, Robert,
you're raising your value.
You've gone from
$2-Million value on the company
to 3.3.
Yes, and I still think that
that's probably undervalued.
Now I'm finding a flaw
in your character.
You see, you came in here
and you offered that--
not a flaw in my character,
sir.
Robert, hang on a sec.
Are you considering his offer?
No. No, I'm--I'm--
I'm countering with a diff--
All right. I'm gonna have to
stay firm on that offer.
My ticket to enter
is my time and $200,000
and 25%.
Uh, 25%--It's--
25% is Still too high.
Yeah, then it comes down
to a "Yes" Or "No," Robert.
We're great partners, man.
You're 75%. I'm 25%.
Be true to yourself.
Robert, I'll give you
more cash.
♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Daymond's made an offer
of $200,000
for a 25% stake.
But Robert may have had
a change of heart.
Robert, I'll give you
more cash.
I'll give you $300,000
for 25%.
My vision
is slightly different.
I gotta tell you, when you have
something beautiful and rare,
you can charge more for it.
Did you just jump in
on my geek?
I sure did.
He did.
(Kevin) Well, let's summarize
what you've got here.
Daymond made you an offer
of $200,000 for 25%,
valuing your company
at $800,000.
And while you were whining
about that,
Robert made you an offer
for $300,000 for 25%,
valuing your company now
at $1.2 million.
Pee-Wee the fruit fly,
what are you gonna do?
Could you--could you bring
your offer up
to match--To match
Robert's offer at this point?
I cannot, because my time
is worth...
because your time is--
I-I--that's fair.
That's completely fair.
Uh, so..
I'm s--Thank you, Daymond.
Really, I appreciate
what you're-- what you're doing--
You taking out
the buzz saw now?
You want 25% of my company,
but then again, you said
you don't get geek,
and you don't
really understand it...
yes.
And that--And I think that's
probably not--
That's probably not
a good fit.
I told you, our vision
may not be on course.
That's a decision
you have to make.
I think maybe that's--That's
probably not a good idea.
Robert, um...
I thought you were out.
That's the beauty
of the shark tank.
Anything can change.
Robert,
I'd like to accept
your offer.
Let's do this. We're gonna
make a lot of money.
You got a deal.
We're gonna make
a lot of money.
We sure are.
Thank you, Robert.
Beautiful. Thank you.
Thank you.
You just partnered
with a termite.
Hey, listen, listen...
(sharks laughing)
He's gonna be good for me.
You could've been
good for me, too.
♪♪
The fruit fly and the termite.
(Lori and Robert laugh)
It's a fable.
I think you definitely suck,
Robert.
You stole that one from me.
Oh, I feel really good
about that one.
I feel good. I feel good.
I hope that this is gonna be
a great partnership
and that, uh, Robert--
The two Robert geeks
will unite
to form
a-a more powerful entity.
Earlier this season,
Aaron Krause
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for his high-tech
scrubbing tool Scrub Daddy.
It won't scratch
any of your surfaces,
but it will
clean them beautifully.
I'm pretty confident
that we could
get this into retail stores
within literally weeks.
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪
So many exciting things
have happened since "Shark Tank"
in such a short amount of time.
Lori helped me get Scrub Daddy
into every Bed Bath & Beyond
store nationwide.
(laughs)
Hi, Lor.
Hi!
How are you?
When I was on
the "Shark Tank,"
Lori did make me a promise
that she's make me a millionaire
within a year,
and that hasn't happened.
It's actually happened
in a matter of weeks.
In the six months
before "Shark Tank,"
I had only done
about $110,000 in sales.
And now we've topped $2 million
in just 15 weeks.
I'm gonna give Scrub Daddy
a really good workout.
This represents your kitchen
countertops, your cabinets,
all your kitchen surfaces--
and look.
(Lori) On QVC, we have sold
500,000 Scrub Daddies.
I would definitely say
scrub daddy
is one of my best investments
to date.
Aaron is a true entrepreneur,
the real deal.
And I think the Scrub Daddy
has the potential
to be a $100-million product.
He's back to bright,
fresh, and clean every time.
(woman) Whoo!
(laughs)
(Aaron) I think "Shark Tank"
is not just an inspiration,
it's a motivator.
The show
makes people think that,
you know what?
I can do that.
I can go out there
and create a product
and I could get an investment
and grow my own business.
♪♪
Next up is Paige Dellavalle
and Ashley Jung,
whose business was inspired
by their experience
in the U.S. Army.
Hey, sharks. I'm Paige.
And this is my sister
and business partner Ashley.
Our company
is called Stella Valle,
and we are here today
seeking $150,000
for a 25% stake
in our company.
When we were West Point Cadets
and army officers,
we never got used
to looking like this
when what we really wanted
to look like was this.
(sharks laugh)
Wow. I'm joining the army.
(Lori and Robert laugh)
(Robert) Wow.
(Lori laughs)
(laughs)
So we started a jewelry line
Unlike any other
to encourage individuality
and self-expression.
Even though this army fatigues
camouflage our creativity,
we had a clear vision
for our life after the military.
It was time for us to leave
conformity behind,
and Stella Valle was born.
It's an accessories line
that reflects our
innate sense of style
and our unique background.
Just like Paige and I,
the line was designed
to perfectly marry masculine
and feminine characteristics.
We have major retailers
like Bloomingdale's
and Henri Bendel,
along with numerous boutiques
selling our line.
We've proven that our product
is marketable
on a small scale,
and now need the capital
to grow Stella Valle
into a global brand
reaching many retailers.
We have faced adversaries
much tougher than a shark.
We are ready to meet
a business partner
as determined as we are
to grow the Stella Valle brand
as strong
as the U.S. Army.
Very nice.
Wow. Great presentation.
(Lori) Wow.
Thank you.
You were officers...
Yes. Yes.
In the army, both of you?
So proud of you.
Where did you serve?
I was in Afghanistan
for 15 months.
Oh, my God.
You are amazing.
Wow.
So impressed.
Thank you.
Tell us about your start
of the company.
Ashley and I actually
got out the same exact week
out of the military,
and we knew that we wanted
to be businesswomen
and we wanted to start
a company together.
We started out small
and We just continued
to grow our business,
because we reinvested every
single dollar that we've made--
What are your sales like?
How much have you sold of this?
Our total sales to date
is about $75,000.
Over what period of time?
So last year was
our first full year of sales,
and we did about $37,000.
But we're projected this year
to sell about $80,000.
So are you currently in
Bloomingdale's and Henri Bendel?
We recently just had two
really successful trunk shows
in Bloomingdale's
and Henri Bendel.
What--what's a trunk show?
A trunk show is where
the store asks you to come up
and set up your stuff exactly--
sort of like we have here,
and we would stand there
as designers
and just talk to
the end customer about our line,
show them how it works, um--
Did Bloomingdale
pick it up then?
The national buyer was
so impressed with our sales,
she does not doubt that we could
triple, if not more, our sales.
And she's confirmed
three additional trunk shows
for, um, our brand.
Why would they keep asking you
to come back and do trunk shows
and simply not pick it up
and distribute it
throughout Bloomingdale's?
They're testing.
They're taking you broader.
Right.
They're trying to see
how people are reacting--
'cause they're not sure.
Well--
What are the average prices?
Retail, our products range
anywhere from $50 to $375.
Okay.
Can we look at them?
I'd love to see them.
Absolutely.
Which one of you
is the designer?
I actually do more
of the creative work,
um, but we collaborate
on the design.
We kind of pass things
back and forth
and then, uh, decide
on our collection.
We basically have
three collections here,
so our first collection
was all create your own,
and you actually can unscrew
all of these charms
so that the customer
can create their own.
So buy extra ones
and put 'em in?
That's looks good on you, Lori.
(laughs)
I'm liking this.
What--What are your costs
for your $50 item
all the way up
to your $375 item?
$3 to $45 per piece.
Your $3 cost items you sell
retail for how much?
Uh, $96.
Sorry. Your retail is $96,
and you make it for $3?
Yes.
That's unbelievable margin.
Do you see most of your sales
in the future
coming from each
of your collections,
or build your own where
somebody has to be present
to help the people?
We're asking for $150,000,
and we did that for
a very specific reason.
What we wanna do is to, um,
take the idea
of the trunk show
And, uh, replicate it
across many different stores.
Why do you even need
to go there?
Why do you need to do
trunk shows?
If--If Bloomingdale
likes the sales,
why wouldn't they just pick
it up, sell it nationally?
They probably will.
Eventually they will.
That's what we've been told.
This is--
I see this absolutely
in a store like Bloomingdale's
or Bendel.
What does this sell for?
$375 retail.
Yeah. $375.
(Kevin) $375.
We made it for $49.
$49. Wow.
It's all Swarovski Crystal.
So basically this is
very expensive
costume jewelry, right?
We have so many people
that come in here,
trying to sell jewelry.
The tank is full of jewelry,
but yours is different
because of where you came from.
(Lori) Mm-hmm.
Right.
Well, here's the bad news.
You're not worth $600,000.
We think we are.
So...
I don't think so.
And we've based that off
of what we've made in the past,
and also the opportunities
that we have--
You haven't made
anything yet.
We've made $75,000
in revenue.
In sales.
Exactly.
(Mark) ignore him.
You know what, guys?
At some point, you just have
to look at somebody
who just doesn't get it
and say, "Next?"
So just ask him,
"are you in or are you out?"
(Ashley and Paige laugh)
So the question is, you haven't
made any money yet, have you?
If we can replicate
ten trunk shows
across any retailer,
worst case scenario,
we sell $500 a day revenue,
we will generate in 60 days
$300,000.
I can't get to your $600,000
valuation right now.
I would never give you $150,000
for only 25%.
To me, that's what
the whole thing's worth today.
I'm out.
What's your logic
for replicating yourselves
as opposed to just
trying to get the big order
in Bloomingdale's
or other retailers?
We think we have to get
the name out there
before you can just put it
on a shelf
and people are coming in there
for Stella Valle.
We don't have
that brand recognition yet.
One of the hardest things
to build is a brand.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
I'm not sure I agree
with the strategy.
I'm out.
Just to talk to that point
a little bit, though.
When we got into Henri Bendel
and Bloomingdale's,
they didn't know our story.
We went into an open call
and stood in line
with 500 other designers,
and we went,
and we showed our designs
to the buyer of Henri Bendel,
and they loved our designs.
They didn't know anything
about Ashley and I yet.
And we are the brand,
and I think if we
can get our story
out there,
people will come seeking
our jewelry.
Paige and Ashley, I think
it's--It's an amazing story,
but, um...
we both have
business degrees.
We're ready to run
the company.
We just need the money,
and that's what
we want from you.
(Kevin laughs)
And the connection.
And--And any connection
you have.
Listen, you're--You're very...
I'm gonna have to close
my eyes a minute,
'cause you're gonna convince me,
which I don't want
to be convinced.
Daymond, this girl served for 15
months in Afghanistan for you.
All right.
Come on.
For your freedom...
(laughter)
So... ah--
while you are making money!
You cannot back out on us.
♪♪
Two sharks are out,
and Paige and Ashley
are trying to convince Daymond
not to become the third.
Daymond,
we know that you can.
I'm gonna have to close
my eyes a minute,
'cause you're gonna
convince me,
which I don't want
to be convinced.
Daymond, this girl served
15 months in Afghanistan
for you.
All right.
While you are making money...
um...
she's getting shot at.
Come on.
(Robert) Wow, guilt trip.
You cannot back out on us.
(Kevin) Oh, I love it.
I love it.
Please don't.
Mark? Lori?
There's your vice president
of sales right there.
Come on.
Listen, I have to be honest,
but I really just don't like
the jewelry. I'm out.
Lori.
Come on, Lori.
Mark. Come on.
I think there's something
very interesting here.
I love your story.
I love the combination
of all of it together.
Everybody in our country
cares so much about all of you
that have fought for us,
and I think
there's something there.
This being jewelry that's...
for women with power,
but I also think, you know,
in my mind,
if a percentage of the proceeds
went to the military...
we actually designed, um,
a screw
in the create-your-own,
which is a star,
and it's engraved "U.S.A."
and we donate a portion
of the proceeds
to the Wounded Warrior Project.
Um, and Ashley actually
mentors a wounded soldier.
I love these girls, Mark,
and I think that there is
something special here.
I think the jewelry
is great-looking.
I think that we could
design even more things
that could be this cool, edgy,
powerful kind of jewelry
from your background.
You can't pay $600,000
for this.
But, Mark... would you like
to go in with me?
I think that we can...
all together make this is a hit.
Do you see this
as a QVC product?
I think it could be, yes.
See, I-I actually like
the fact that it might not be
a QVC product.
I think they need everything,
Mark.
My gut feeling
is you need stores.
I think QVC would give you
free advertising
and get your name
and your brand out there,
and you can create
special pieces just for QVC.
I think there's a lot
that could be done with it.
There's a lot to it.
Especially with how proud
we are of your background.
I think that story
is really powerful.
Um, mark,
if you go in with me...
Mm-hmm.
Maybe 30% of the company.
I'd rather put in
a little bit more cash
and get a little bit more
of the company than 30%
because if there's
two of us,
there's gotta be enough
skin in the game.
And for what it's worth,
I started an organization
called
the Fallen Patriot Fund.
It's something I believe in,
so what if we both put up 100k--
$200,000 for 40% of the company?
That way, you have more cash,
you have more expertise,
and we both have enough skin
in the game.
I think $150,000 is where
we should stick
at 30 or 35% of the company.
We'll do 150k for 35%, okay?
Lori and I together.
I'm on that deal, Mark.
By the way, You'd be insane
not to take that.
We don't want any more talking,
right?
So what are you gonna do?
Mark and Lori,
we accept your offer.
All right.
Yeah.
(Lori) Great.
Thank you.
(laughs)
It's done.
Great.
(Mark) Good, good.
(Daymond) Ohh.
Yay!
(laughs) Thank you,
thank you. Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
(Lori) You're awesome.
(Kevin) Wow.
To think that we started
our business with a $1,000 loan,
and now we're business partners
with Mark Cuban
and Lori Greiner, this--This is
a dream come true for us.